in the lobby of Ramsey's solutions Ross
is with us hey Ross hey how you doing
welcome man good to have you where do
you live I'm in ester California cool
what brings you to Nashville there's my
free ice cream Dave all the way here
just for you I love it well we're
honored to have you sir how much have
you paid off
I paid off three hundred and eight
thousand dollars in 36 38 months boom I
love it very cool and I'm making what
kind of income during that time we
started out a hundred and ten ended up
125 110 to 125 yes okay that doesn't add
up you must have sold something to pay a
three well well Dave my wife and I were
married 36 years and she passed away
five months ago
oh my gosh yeah so we've been on a
little bit of journey and this is the
end of the season right now so yeah yeah
so she just passed it off you go yeah so
what happened well so what happened was
six years ago
my wife and I were she was cleaning up
for Christmas and all of a sudden she
fell does something interesting
neck got and she started going I can't
wake up and we walked in virgin see she
stopped walking and something happened
in her spinal cord they never really
figured it out and then over when we
came back from rehab we we had to have
somebody come stay with us so we ended
up short selling our house and we ended
up God provided a rental for us right
down the street a beautiful house half
the mortgage and we had some room and
boy I'm just excited but we a year later
I was walking with a friend a co-worker
and she's mentioned you and I got came
home and and got online and so who you
were and everything and and told my wife
about it and she was on board and we
joined a class and we paid off our
seventy eight thousand dollars and 20
months and that was between her and I
yeah and at that point she was a
quadriplegic paraplegic and so what did
she have they just think it may be she
had a stroke in her neck or something
they don't never know at the University
in
San Francisco and and I just became
degenerative type thing we went to
therapy and everything else and and our
next goal was to you know build our
emergency fund and we over the next year
as we did that we built our emergency
fund and we actually were able to get
back into our house and the month that
we finished our emergency for them was
last August and we were she went in a
hospital and I was thinking there that
this is what financial peace feels like
through all the storms for all the stuff
that we've gone through this is what you
know I can just forget about the money
my kids were having trouble you know
trying to keep things here some money
here somebody just let's focus on mom
and our goal was to pay off her house in
the next six years because we were just
on fire and over the next three months
she was in and out of hospital and
passed away November last year and we
had some life insurance and but it
wasn't enough to pay off the house and
and I told god I'm gonna tithe on that
anyway and a week later I was talking to
her long-term disability provider and
they said well you know she had life
insurance with I said no I didn't know
anything about that she said they said
yeah we've been paying the principal for
the last six years and we have a check
for $120,000 for you and I and I
instantly just paid off my house I've
finished it and what's amazing Dave is
one December 30th six years to the day I
was in the bank doing a wine transfer to
pay off my loan and it was like it
closed my wife paid it off and God paid
it off and it was just the end of that
season you know so it's been amazing
what God has done and and and what your
program has done for me because it saved
my financial future and I really feel so
blessed about my wife because she even
in a wheelchair she could have been
shopping or doing anything but she she
was worried about me and it helped me
want to do this so really an amazing
story and one thing you don't know Dave
but last September we actually had a
financial piece class schedule at our
church and we had one person enrolled
because we were my wife was in a
wheelchair but we were gonna do the
class anyway and she went in the
hospital in August and and so that got
counsel but Joshua called
Joshua Collier he's my financial coach
and that man was praying with me while I
was in the hospital and I just really
appreciate your organization because
there they stood for me he stood with me
and what's really exciting Dave through
all this is next Tuesday I in modesto at
my house the house church Modesto with
you this family strong group we're
putting on a class next Tuesday and I
have FPU class I'm hosting and we have
over 50 people already signed up so I'm
very excited about this right so so you
were married 36 36 years old was she
when she passed she was 66 years old
yeah what was her first name teri teri
so we're gonna call this the teri
memorial fbu class then right yeah
definitely Thanks definitely because she
was obviously into this that's amazing
yeah and that that so the the life
insurance finishes the goal yeah the two
of you had to get yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was it's it's been a grief is very
powerful and yes it sneaks up it sneaks
up on you and it comes in waves doesn't
it yeah but when you don't have any
financial problems to worry about if I
was back in that old house a house
beautiful house that we started this
whole thing we would have I would have
been in ruins right now yeah but God
provided a nice smaller house nicer
house paid for house and I'm sitting
here and I'm just he gave you a brain to
make the disaster yes yes and he gave me
a new ministry do this find out your
piece is my is my calling and I'm really
feel strongly about it we're honored to
have you yeah absolutely amazing
yes well we're about to have a Terry
memorial debt-free scream as well and
you know I as I hear you talk I think
about the state of California and
there's so many folks who listen in
every day and they doubt that this is
possible in that economic climate and
here you are there's a lot of them say
that it's actually impossible to tie the
that economic climate here you are
talking about tithing and how you've
been blessed with that and then doing
this with all the illness and I just
want to say you've really inspired
millions of people today but you've also
inspired a state that says that it's not
that's right that's right it is possible
and it was like you said once we we did
a zero zero budget is like we got a
raise and it just opened our minds and
we just went for it and and God made it
way right every time we needed we need
to help it was there and and and now
with my with my with my church my god
and my kids and everything I have a lot
of good support and and even though it's
it's very painful and stuff to go
through but I just know the future is
bright the future is bright it is
whatever it holds without a doubt Wow
dude what a story man thank you for
coming all the way from Modesto to
spirit here and in person absolutely
amazing all right Ross and Terry from
Modesto California three hundred and
eight thousand dollars paid off in 36 to
38 months making 110 to 125 during that
time and living a journey count it down
let's hear a debt free scream this is
for you honey
1 2 3
Wow Wow
unbelievable hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind